bien écouter on est ravi de vous avoir
alors je vous présente tout le monde
vous connaît mais enfin je veux quand
même rappeler qu'ils vous êtes vous êtes
le 29 février déjà ça c'est
extraordinaire c'est votre anniversaire
s'étirer et et médisants l'an dernier ah
oui c'est ça s'est su tenir la barre du
chef véronique vous traduisez pour asia
oui série no mercy véronique elle est
soumise véronique j'ai bien dans ce club
c'est vrai donc votre père vous a vu
vous en faites vous êtes né dans un
faubourg d'oran un vote perd donc
s'occuper du garage de la police à oran
votre mère elle faisait des ménages
huit enfants oui beaucoup vt sous le
drapeau français ce qui fait que j'ai
beaucoup de problèmes à savoir si vous
êtes français ou algérien et d'ailleurs
quand vous avez l'étranger vous êtes
souvent reçue par l'ambassadeur de
france
c'est vrai et au mexique c'était le
consul de france ne voulait pas en
parler de ça non j'étais petit goût de
ses silences donc vous réclamez la
nationalité française depuis cinq ans
vous l'avez n'ont toujours pas donc je
t'en parle
qui de droit
à 6 ans à l'âge de 6 ans vous vendiez de
la limonade à crier dans les rues pour
aider votre famille à vivre la limonade
se situe quand même pas une limonade
très beaucoup d'eau un petit rond quand
même voilà sucre et cinq centièmes en
même temps c'est pas très cher
très jeune vous êtes intéressé par la
musique par contrat le soumet aussi par
johnny hallyday donc influences mêlées à
bob marley aussi d'ailleurs et à ces
temps vous fabriquez votre première
guitare de devaux marc à 9 ans vous
chantez dans les mariages à 11 ans et
votre propre groupe
un groupe s'appelait le cinq étoiles
quel est votre premier groupe oui c'est
ça à 14 ans renvoyé de l'école
bravo avec une bonne note des beaux arts
sens et là vous commencez faut dire la
vérité à l'aide à traîner dans les
cabarets un peu pas trop parler soir
parce que nous est surveillante n'est
pas de constituer au moins dans les
endroits où vous aviez si dans les
boîtes dans le cambouis
pourquoi
bon alors vous avez l'esprit rails un
très jeune vous avez d'esprit lancé quoi
l'esprit rails
parce que ces composés d'alcool de
cabaret et prostituée et un peu de
drogue non goudronnée aquatique du maroc
ovum drogues douces ont fait venir pas
drogues dures le mot riders ça veut dire
opinions et voilà quoi c'est parce que
en tant qu on était jeunes on a on
n'avait pas beaucoup de liberté
je pense que j'ai découvert cette
musique qui existait depuis longtemps et
que les radios les tunisiens pour vous
ne voulez pas passer ça c'est quand je
pense que c'est comme l'histoire du
rock'n'roll quoi gens qui disaient que
dans sa danse avec les ronces et
bordélique combien c'est par exemple si
c'est une chanson qui nous rendent dans
la débauche alors il y avait des gens
qui n'acceptait pas sa et la chanson raï
ccc c'est tous des métaphores des baux
conditionnait temps pour cesser pour
s'exprimer et c'est aussi pour casser le
tabou
ouais vous souvenez un premier 45 tours
vous avez déjà des ennuis avec les
intégristes faut dire que sur la face b
y avait une fille avait le vent qui
soulever la jupe envoyer des plex dans
ce c'était ma génération et je voulais
dire ce que je pensais à saison vous
êtes une star c'est jerry en algérie oui
mais c'est plus vite quand même à 26 ans
vous arrivez en france il y avait 6 ans
vous en rêviez à 26 ans pourquoi vous
venez en france simplement parce que les
amoureux peuvent se donner la main oui
je pense que c'était un rêve de chaque
jeune comme ici à un petit jeune
français qui rêvent de voir les états
unis nous ont appris qu du nom parce
qu'on maîtrise bien français on rêve
qu'est ce qui n'a pas ce rêve nous rêver
a dit y avait des mains quand j'étais
petit qui parlait de zizou et qui se
péter la galerie aux puissants
j'aimerais bien voir de la tour eiffel
et mourir quoi c'était un rêve de
semaine celui de sauter voilà justement
très vite à risquer leur vie d'exil en
bateau dans les cales et tout part en
france en france on pouvait se donner la
main on peut aussi un peu un peu picolé
c'est vrai aussi par j il y avait cette
hypocrisie quand on va dans des mariages
on voit les gens ils sont sont
tranquilles et de soi quand ils sortent
ils ont pété on voit pas les bouteilles
quoirin par exemple à te voir dans les
thermos de café ya une série d'accords
bien sûr respect tout le monde connaît
tout le monde tout le monde reconnaît
que le tel type il fréquente elle bat où
on avait dernièrement mais problème
c'est que les gens tels mots qui
picolent vite alors à 9 heures c'est
fini quand il n'ya plus du talent qu on
attendait est ce que la religion
musulmane la tradition 10 on n'a pas le
droit de voir d'un accord il saura t'on
dit il faut pas pratiquer la prière
automne d'irriter stade il faut pas
tromper tard quand on sait la prière des
gens qui lisait le coran dont on va
savoir
et le gars est venu pas avec eux devant
le bon dieu en train de prix là il a
oublié sauras tu sais comment surmonter
montebourg et je chante une chanson
après j'oublie mes textes n'ont toujours
pas annoncé par exemple que mon père en
france à oran parce que moi j'habite à
l'ouest d'algérie
on est plus en dalles ou si c'est qu'on
lui mars il comptait gens prenaient ces
cinq ans les miens laurent oui mais moi
chez moi mon père un moment il a stoppé
tout ce qui nous a vus grandir nous
n'avons pas respecté la galerie tout le
monde quoi et mais quand même il savait
comment par exemple préparer une yz
parce que nous les aura laissé des plus
alizade dans le temps jusqu'à maintenant
la misère alors à flot là bas alors y
avait des gars qui sont venus du
quartier selon le gerontology dire alors
vous arrivez en france et vous devenez
le roi du raï avec dj c'est vrai que ça
a été énorme danoise est enregistré à
los angeles
il faut savoir que 10 10 est le premier
tube en arabe dans le top 50
alors vous êtes quand même bon vous êtes
grand amateur de deux femmes et d'alcool
tout le monde le sait on ce n'est pas un
secret et un jour votre mère débarque
bonne humeur des bars pendant dire grand
amateur de femmes et d'alcool c'est
sexiste
elle a dit oui j'ai des choses de la vie
dont les femmes et l'alcool ça va ça j'y
arriverai jamais vous aimez bien
j'aimais bien baisés boire
non mais je sais moi ça me gêne de dire
ça à moi personnellement j'aurais dit
vous êtes un grand amateur d'alcool et
de femmes je sais je sais mais chaque
hausse de 10 à peine 11 ans mais leur
bord un jour il n'a pas répondu thierry
ce n'était pas une question c'est une
altération formation
un jour un jeune âge ou sa mère débarque
elle demande à khaled hemidi maintenant
monfils faut que tu te maries et elle
arrive à ces femmes c'est à dire vous
marier avec samira vous mariez grave
haute mer comme tu peux pousser quand
même chanter et elle reste elle reste
ici au début elle est clandestine puis
après fait tellement chez la préfecture
ça finisse par donner des papiers ça
c'est vrai échec
c'est pour dire à tous les immigrés si
vous faites autant chez la préfecture
l'anr de râler quand même gentil alors
vallée de l'ach obligé de vous en parler
on va pas faire une demi heure là dessus
c'est vrai que l'on parle beaucoup de
vous aussi dans la rubrique faits divers
quand on reçoit des trucs qu'on sait à
la gueule
on dit alors il n'y a pas de juste et
c'est ce journalisme qu'ils utilisent
c'est ce à quoi vous en souffrez défaut
il ya des affaires qui sont en cours et
c est ce qu on dit dans un journal c'est
fini on est jugé et condamné
ça c'est vrai je pense que maintenant la
presse moi je respecte la presse mais la
presse et le public c'est le peuple
c'est la presse moi j'ai toujours
défendu la presse est aujourd'hui c'est
des gars qui sont super sénégal qui qui
qui donnent leur vie pour nous ramener
l'information on a bien plusieurs
journalistes qui sont morts en algérie
autant que ce qui se passe au monde mais
mais mais le problème faut pas dire
n'importe quoi il faut pas écrire avec
son pied quand même il faut vraiment
mettre les choses à sa place est
vraiment expliqué
mais c'est beau c'est à ranger vos
affaires là ça va mieux bon j'espère ses
heures j'espère du bio que je sais
pourquoi pas réglé ses problèmes une
fois pour toute et puis j'espère
j'espère j'espère j'espère mais je pense
que j'étais toujours un bonheur qui aime
la vie je suis toujours un boulot qui a
la force de rigoler laverie un peu moins
a tout de suite mais bon pas non non pas
du tout parce que khaled pour n'y voyez
aucune ironie en haut mais on va faire
une unité a vu dernier coup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dernier coup de coeur dernier coup de
coeur coups de coeur c'est chez moi
maman retour et ce que j'ai fais
vraiment ça ouais j'ai regardé beaucoup
et vous voilà dans les coups de poing
dans les coups de poing là je pense je
peux pas dire coup de poing ce chéri
j'ai lu ici c'est une luge en plus parce
que c'est vrai alors c'est vraiment un
accident c'est ça vient de quelqu'un
c'est même l'un de nos bourgs pu
vérifier sont pas là les coups de foudre
d'aller coup de foudre dans les coups de
foudre c'est attention à ce que vous
dites ou non ne vous inquiétez pas dans
les coups de foudre belle écoute route
jcc méfie toi je suis j'ai ma fille qui
a 4 ans dès fois me fais moi rhône est
grave kwame brown et moi et la maman
quad et dallas on a un coup de foudre
non dit j'ai envie de des fois quand on
embarque à l'école j'ai envie que ça te
revient 6 environ 80 pour virement
l'année va chercher la bouffe est quoi
un dernier coup de rouge d'en découdre
où ça fait 3 enfin vous avez arrêté de
boire
oui mais quoi que dise globe n'ont pas
de boulot même pas pu puisque je suis je
suis je pense que je suis devenu un
petit peu méchant quand même parce que
quand on boit beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
à un moment où les nerfs le joker vous
l'avez déjà il faut savoir il faut
savoir vous l'avez dit khaled dernier
coup de bluff est maintenant là
maintenant je suis bluffé la dernier
coup de blues dernier christophe dard et
coups de blues d'aller coup de blues
passé récent vous avez un mauvais un
coup de blues d'un coup de blues quand
on tape à la porte à nous ici pour les
aime pour vous donner un conseil à tous
les jeunes chanteurs bien vous dit de
payer vos impôts
non mais c'est vrai mais quand on trouve
que déjà pour leur donne des chèques et
qui reviennent et après tout ajoute des
majorations encaissé après is it on va
lui six ans et vos dernières questions
dernier coup de rein huissier et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou